when our city started to
collapse the Dark Side of humanity took
control of the
streets this city fell
apart it's crazy out here every man for
himself survival of the
fittest you got to take what you need in
this
world this world is our Playground now
and no one's here to stop
us we got out of Riker's
jail and we ain't ever going back in the
hole it's all ours now we're the new
Kings of these
streets these streets must be s
sanitized to save our city we must burn
away this
disease every trace of it no matter the
cost freedom is not a right Liberty is
not a given this city needs an iron fist
to restore order there shall be no
[Music]
resistance no matter who stands in our
way
there's always another
way our mission is to save what
remains to save what's left of our
[Music]
city we are the
division
[Music]
a